[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire on va commencer cette
émission avec pas compte tellement pour
son livre l'en quête infinie qui
racontent une autre histoire du 20e
siècle plus ésotériques qui va du sphinx
à philip k.dick je recevrai ensuite jean
charles de castelbajac dont les
meilleurs dessins sont réunis dans
dessins tout terrain et seront exposées
au centre pompidou du 25 septembre au 9
mai et l'on terminera avec ludmilla à
baline sky arthur en scène le célèbre
duo de plaine chemist classique a créé
le festival rungis piano piano qui se
tiendra du 25 septembre au 4 octobre
c'est le premier festivals en france
consacré au duo de piano et l'on
commence tout de suite par vous pacôme
thiellement voici l'image que vous avez
choisie pour illustrer ce début de 21e
siècle c'est une toile de olivia clavel
que représente-t-elle alors elle
représente carl gustav jung et philip
k.dick en train de tirer le yi king et
j'anticipe sur votre prochaine question
qui est peut-être pourquoi est-ce que
j'ai choisi pour représenter parce que
j'ai lu votre livre et je sais que j'en
parle et où libé et de l'est dit qu'on
l'a dit de young aussi on va en parler
vous mais alors pourquoi ce tableau est
il si important à parce que olivia
clavel grande grande peintre et
dessinatrice voyante a bien saisi qu'il
y avait quelque chose de central dans le
geste le geste de philip k dick et de
carl gustav jung même si peut-être au
moment où elle le peigné ne le savent et
elles pas ce sera à elle de le dire mais
ils ont écrit tous les deux pour moi les
deux textes fondateurs clé 2
on pourrait dire les nouveaux testaments
gnostique et de les deux principaux
nouveaux testaments gnostique le livre
rouge de young écrit entre 1913 à 1916
mai publiée seulement en 2009 qui
influencent et yom qui va influence
énormément de gens ya une horrible david
bowie y compris david bowie combrée
fellini y compris les beatles etc et
philip k dick qui lui a rédigé son
exégèse donc de 1914
1982 de textes qui se revendique un de
l'héritage des gnostiques donc c'est pas
juste l'interprétation c'est vraiment le
c'est vraiment le geste lui-même qui les
ai dit qu'il lui va avoir une influence
sur toute la fiction qui suis de toute
façon bon bah on est déjà dans le coeur
du sujet l'en quête infinie donc qui
vient de paraître aux puf les presses
universitaires de france c'est très
sérieux à les presses universitaires de
france est pour toi ô mon dieu vous
raconter une toute autre histoire du 20e
siècle que celle que l'on connaît alors
je vous cite le problème de ce monde
écrivait vous dès le début du livre
c'est qu'on est entré comme dans une
histoire qu'on a attrapé en cours de
route une histoire dont on a raté le
début qui nous est arrivé incomplète et
plein d'incohérences ça n'a pas fait
bondir votre éditeur attendait au
tourisme il a l'habitude maintenant
laurent de sutter ça fait plusieurs
plusieurs livres souvent ici vous avez
reçu ici et que je salue non il enfin
j'espère que de temps en temps je les
fait bondir de surprise ou d'amusement
mais disons qu'il est il n'a pas trouvé
saab erreur de ma part de commencer un
livre comme c'est peut être parce à deux
pas de la part des presses
universitaires de france on verra la
suite mais alors comment sont votre
commençons votre livre par là où il
commence le sphinx ou le xv hinx on sait
toujours pas ce qu'est le sphinx on n'en
sait toujours rien rien ne serait
presque ça fait partie de ce début de
l'histoire qu'on a ratés ap comme quoi
les vêtements oui oui masse et on est
rentré dans l'histoire comme un ver
exactement comme dans un récit dans le
temps a raté le début est typiquement le
sphinx basse et des épisodes qu'on a
loupé c'est l'épisode on a loupé on sent
candidate à peu près il ya des gens qui
des estimations mais qui sont éloignés
de millénaire si vous voulez donc oui ça
serait ça devrait être la haute egypte
si on en croit les si on en croit les
experts il fallut un million d'heures
pour le construire un million d'heures
ce qui est pas mal mais surtout on ne
sait pas ce qu'ils représentaient pour
les anciens égyptiens parce que la
première chose qui est surprenant quand
on parle du sphinx et que le sphinx
n'appartient pas à la mythologie
égyptienne la mythologie disant jésus
bien celle avec osiris il y sort hussein
et le sphinx n'apparaît jamais il se
fixe c'est probablement pas le nom qui
leur donnait puisque c'est le nom que
les grecs lui en donner les grecs qui
sont venus les pharaons mais très
tardivement c'est l'époque de cléopâtre
très tardivement la seule la seule
référence à la statue elle même elle est
dans une stèle qui a été rajouté qui est
la stèle de ceux de ce pharaon là tout
mosys qui l'a désensabler celui qu'il a
dix ans avec parce que poème du sphinx
et qui sans sable facilement il faut
dire que cet endroit il ya beaucoup de
tempêtes de sable et que donc il
disparaît et réapparaît examen est la
dernière fois qu'il est réapparue qu'au
19e siècle tout à fait tout à fait on a
on a dû leur désensabler intégral à on
l'avait oublié aussi c'est elle qui on
l'a retrouvé non mais c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose d'assez mystérieux
bah oui oui c'est assez fou c'est à dire
que non seulement on sait pas comment il
l'appelait on sait pas ce qu'il
représente et pour on sait même pas
vraiment ce que c'est c'est à dire que
c'est une tête d'homme sur un corps
d'animal mais est ce que c'est un corps
de lion est ce que c'est un corps de
boeuf est ce que c'est là un peu des
deux est ce que c'est il y en a même qui
ont dit que c'était un chien
il est tout à tout un tas d'éléments
comme ça qui font que le sphinx reste
associé à l'énigme parce que ce qui va
être dans la mythologie grecque par
contre puisque les grecs vont avoir un
sphinx dans leur mythologie on sait pas
si le sphinx de leur mythologie est
inspiré par cette statue ou si le nom
qu'ils ont donné de statut quand ils
l'ont découverte vient du nom de la
bestiole qui avaient dans leur
mythologie oui mais le sphinx des grecs
bon le connais un peu plus alors dans
celui qui cinq ans on ira mystère votre
livre et puis après on va en inde
égrainé un certain nombre par exemple qu
y at il de commun entre les poètes que
vous citez juste après après le sphinx à
savoir victor hugo
jarre de nerval charles baudelaire
arthur rimbaud lautréamont
mallarmé alfred jarry on les voit tous
défilé la wii ea compte ils en commun à
vos yeux alors j'ai utilisé à ce moment
là quand je les ai égrainé comme ça
comme un chapelet c'est exactement la
liste qu'a fait andré breton dans
flagrant délit au regard des bretons
qu'on va voir également il ya un texte
très important parce que c'est un texte
qui dans l'est à la fin de la vie
d'andré breton est en fait une réponse
aux personnes qui croient encore que le
faux rimbaud la chasse spirituelle est
vraiment de rimbaud dire qu'elle ce
forain bon on connaît l'histoire
maintenant elle a été raconté plusieurs
fois ces deux acteurs qui veulent se
venger parce qu'ils ont joué une saison
d'enfer au théâtre on les a critiqués et
spécialiste de rimbaud comme
comment s'appelle-t-il déjà pascal pia
voilà pascal pia leur avait dit si
j'avais trouvé la chasse spirituelle je
n'aurais jamais confier jusqu'au vous
êtes capable de faire de nos textes de
rimbaud alors ils ont voulu venger ils
ont fait une fausse joie spirituelle
texte qui avait été évoqué dans des
lettres de verlaine par les textes qui
est supposé avoir été brûlé par la femme
de verlaine et tout le monde voulait
vous retrouver ce texte qui suppose être
un des plus beaux textes de rimbaud dont
breton mais breton quand il voit le faux
rimbaud il se laisse pas avoir là dessus
at il dit en premier temps c'est pas de
rimbaud les autres visées au vieux con
c'est pas parce que tu n'as pas trouvé
etc
ces drames beau et alors ils décident de
le démontrer il fait un long texte pour
le démontrer qu'un texas est admirable
mais qui s'arrête soudain au milieu de
sa démonstration parce qu'il vient de
voir une dépêche afp dans cette dépêche
afp il apprend qu'il ya des textes ghosn
au stick de nag hamadi qui viennent
d'être retrouvés dans une jarre au
milieu du désert en 1945 et donc ça a
été annoncé en 48 c'est pour ça que
c'est un peu plus tardif mais les oies
l'ad'ailleurs ils sont donc les première
fois qu'on trouvait autant de textes
attribués aux gones au stick qui étaient
donc les hérétiques des premiers siècles
chrétiens les adversaires d'une
institution chrétienne ce qu'a voulu
suivre jésus mais ne vais pas voulu
suivre et l'église et qui avait voulu on
va dire
créer un rapport à la spiritualité qui
soit un rapport à la fois égalitaire
années rares chic mais aussi rapports
intimes sans passer par sans passer par
des prêtres d'évêques par des rois
exactement exactement c'est pour ça que
dans les textes eux-mêmes jésus les
appelle les sans droits c'est pour ça
que moi je les appelle les sans droits
depuis plusieurs livres tout essayé de
prendre le nom que jésus leur donner
parce que nos stick un terme péjoratif
mais là breton quand il tombe là dessus
il a il a vraiment un flash je vais me
permets de le citer je suis désolé je
savais pas ce que ce qui est très beau
c'est la manière dont il le dit et je
voudrais pas
comment dire déformé les propos de
breton donc ils disent à l'aigle au
stick sont à l'origine de la tradition
ésotérique qui passe pour s'être
transmise jusqu'à nous or il est
remarquable que les poètes dont l'
influence se montre aujourd'hui la plus
vivace dont l'action sur la sensibilité
moderne se fait le plus sentir hugo
nerval baudelaire rimbaud lautréamont
mallarmé jarry ont été plus ou moins
marqués par cette tradition
mieux même il semble que souvent sans
l'avoir aucunement en vue alors qu'il
s'abandonne et en toute solitude à leur
voix intérieure il leur arrive à de
recouper cette tradition d'abonder dans
son sens par une autre voie il ya là un
grand mystère sur lequel nous sommes
quelques-uns à demeurer pencher alors
c'est ce grand mystère là - qui
m'intéresse ça m'intéresse plus que tout
alors que ce soit cette lignée de poète
breton n'est pas le seul à l'avoir élu
comme la lignée des poètes tout on va
dire forgé notre sensibilité moderne
évidemment arthaud va reprendre les
mêmes eaux peu de choses près il va
rajouter des repos on va la retrouver
chez les membres du grand jeu j'ai
rejoint par le comte chez rené daumal on
va dire que toute cette mouvance g
desnos toute cette mouvance de poètes
vont élire ses sept poètes français on
va dire ajoutant boys dont on peut en
ajouter un ou deux autres c'est pas une
question de faire un c'est enfin c'est
pas grave c'est juste l'idée ça la
construction de cette sensibilité
moderne et que breton la voix comme on
va dire l'anamnèse ou la résurgence la
première grande résurgence
de l'esprit des gnostiques l'esprit des
sans-droits les esprits des gnostiques
c'est vraiment c'est l'égalité qui est
quand même le fondement il ya l'égalite
l'égalité le refus de toute forme de
hiérarchie spirituel donc l'égalité
l'égalité entre les hommes l'égalité
hommes femmes est aussi l'égalité avec
les animaux ils ont un rapport avec les
animaux et alors on vient de voir un
gars allan poe gros bien tu es le faire
là dedans vous en parlait évidemment vu
consacrer un chapitre with et le sait le
père du roman policier où l'assassinât
dans la rue morgue il publie en 1841
c'est le premier roman policier oui
c'est pour être dans la lumière mais
alors là c'est le livre on va dire que
le livre s'ouvre en deux temps il ya un
premier temps global sur le mystère on
va dire c'est le temps global du livre
puis haletant de l'enquète la question
de l'enquète ski intérieur sketch sur le
xxème siècle voilà voilà et c'est
probablement le genre qui définit mois
pour moi c'est le genre qui définit
l'entrée dans le xxème siècle c'est le
roman policier parce que pas seulement
évidemment dans la fiction on peut dire
qu'on va retrouver sa dans la
psychanalyse skinny des transports de
romans policiers pour savoir qui est
coupable de notre complexe d'oedipe et
puis même freud va rapprocher la
l'analyse
2 du déroulement de la pièce oedipe roi
dont on considère qu'elle est une des
premières formes qui annonce le roman
policier puisque dit mène une enquête
sur la mort de lajos il trouve qu'il est
coupable de sa propre enquête mais pau
c'est très particulier parce que pour en
simplement trois nouvelles il va définir
un genre qui va être exploité un nombre
infini de fois très peu de temps après
conan doyle va déjà commencer à le faire
jouer de façon répétitive avec sherlock
holmes le personnage de po c'est auguste
dupin c'est ce détective français mais
surtout il va influencer un type de
défections c'est à dire qu'il va être le
père des profilers et là on fait un saut
dans le temps ayant fait un saut de
méthon 70 ans à peu près quand va
commencer à se créer l'école de
psychologie criminelle de quantico et
les deux premiers grande figure de
profilers robert hesler et john douglas
on se revendiquait en fait des
personnages de fiction seuls les
personnages de fiction ont pu leur
apprendre leur métier de dire auguste
dupin et sherlock holmes pourquoi parce
que c'est une nouvelle ses romans ont
anticipé une méthode de détection
policière qui passe à la fois par la
scène du crime c'est à dire qu'on n'est
plus dans les enquêtes où on peut les
profilers ils vont chercher de serial
killer serial killer qui vont tuer des
gens qui ne connaissent pas
personnellement donc on peut plus faire
l' enquête en regardant autour qu'elle
arrive et là on
exactement tout ça ça ne marche pas donc
on doit rentrer dans la tête du tueur on
doit arriver à saisir la signature du
tueur dans le crime il est rentré dans
la tête pour comprendre sa logique il en
fait on rentre aussi dans quelque chose
qui est pas très loin de la voyance ça
john douglas l'a dit aussi donc on
retrouve les voyants au niveau 1 c'est
john douglas qui le dit la première fois
quand il et il arrive sur la scène du
crime du tueur des sentiers fait la
liste de choses qui définissent le tueur
il termine en disant ah oui j'oubliais
il a un défaut d'élocution glacial et
phlippoteau il dit à trouver ou le
défaut est sidérant de crime ça c'est
formidable et art ou alors le fait est
que tous les poètes convient de voir
enfin la plupart oui quand même des
morts très très particulière traité et
sur lesquelles on n'a pas cessé
d'enquêter et c est certain artaud
convient convient voilà qui dit les
poètes meurent jeunes au fond parce que
parce qu'on a peur que leur poésie
renverse la réalité oui au fond ce
serait savoureux oui votre votre vision
du 20e siècle en fait c'est ce moment où
les poètes ont failli renverser la
réalité et l'ont renversé un certain
nombre d'initiés ceux qui les ont bien
compris pour un certain nombre de
s'initier c'est un terme qui renverrait
justement à une forme inégalitaire on va
dire pour un certain nombre de
deux lecteurs pour ce qu'ils ont ou de
ceux qui les ont lues ce qu'ils ont aimé
ce qu'ils ont voulu ceux qui ont voulu
croire qu'ils ont voulu croire à ce
qu'ils disent et non pas douter d'eux et
artaud 8 hippiques mans va refaire
régulièrement la généalogie de ces
poètes par faire la généalogie de leur
mort c'est vrai que leur moral semble
bizarre avec la mort de poe elle est
incroyable c'est de l'art raconté elle
est absolument hallucinant que toulalan
et nerval son
incroyable salariale et donc ils vont il
dort ducasse morts pendant la guerre de
1870 cependant le siège de parler
lautréamont et voilà votre amour et donc
tous bien sûr ils ont ils ont 6 ans est
mort bizarre et il ya un soupçon wade
arthaud qu'on n'a pas voulu on n'a pas
voulu que le président vienne réel il ya
aussi un soupçon que le véritable
coupable c'est dieu mais c'est le dieu
vivant mauvais dieu le dieu le démiurge
le dieu des gnostiques justement le
diagnostic présente comme le move et
dieu seul huitième la hiérarchie qui
aiment l'ordre qui aiment la domination
entre les hommes la domination que les
hommes et les femmes etc etc et laourou
artaud et une intuition fabuleuse c'est
que en effet dans l'oeuvre de pau il ya
ceux d'août quand même qu'ils aient posé
sur est ce que l'homme ne serait pas
capable de réussir à comprendre les
secrets de dieu est ce que les secrets
de dieu un moment ne peuvent pas il peut
pas l'y peuvent aller ils peuvent aller
choper à les attraper c'est pour ça
qu'il écrirait kms de grands nos grands
textes incroyable très difficile à
comprendre un traître est hermétique
mais au fond c'est réussira à piger le
secret de dieu est arrivé à s'opposer au
plan de dieu et et jack l'éventreur
alors alors jack tu es bon droit il est
là parce que voilà oui pourquoi il est
là c'est sûr il ya beaucoup de
personnages les packs des sympathiques
jack l'éventreur évidemment
j'ai pas du tout le même coup il
pourrait parler avec lui parce qu'il a
alors pour dire très vite parce que
parce qu'il veut être célèbre par le
pire alors là c'est vraiment c'est la
star du pire la star du pire laisse pas
sa gueule c'est c'est son nombre qu'il
projette donc jack l'éventreur c'est une
des premières figures si ce n'est la
première figure de tueurs organisé de
crime a priori gratuit c'est à dire que
ces victimes sont des prostituées dans
les bas fonds de londres qui va tuer de
façon absolument horrible avec à chaque
fois des détails r2 physique perceptible
qui leur enlève un organe il crée une
scène de crime et ça crée une sorte de
terreur dans londres sur une poignée de
crime 1 mais qui vont avoir des on va
dire des réverbérations psychologique
très grande c'est aussi le moment où on
joue dr jekyll et mr hyde de théâtre
donc il ya des tenues tout tout tout un
questionnement qui se fait par rapport à
ça mais surtout c'est le premier qui va
demander cette nouvelle type de
détection à l'époque de jack l'éventreur
ya pas de profilers évidemment il n'ya
pas ça donc il ya deux cent 200 suspects
potentiels et tous les suspects vont
dire quelque chose en fait de la
personne qui les désigne comme suspect
c'est ça qui est très intéressant par
exemple d un des plus connus qui est le
médecin de la reine qui nous voulons un
des moins probable parce que s'il ne
peut être complètement des rentes mais
elle fait au moins trois fictions et ont
fait trois fictions sur cet audit le
plus probable aujourd'hui tout ce que
l'on sait se serait en fait quelqu'un
qui était le chef de la police oui oui
c'est là c'est là c'est la proposition
de software for software fortunes
françaises qui nourrit pour à l'offre
française que je que je félicite que je
salue fait ployer l on leur montre et je
vais aller les voir les spécialistes
will all black jack l'éventreur on les
appelle les rippeurs horlogerie faire
alors oui tout à fait ils sont nombreux
et normalement l'idée qu'ils doivent
trouver comme une nouvelle figure à
savoir
et celle là elle pas ma langue oui on
n'a pas le temps de m'attarder à l'eau
sur carl gustav jung vous en parliez
tout à l'heure on y voit sur la toile
d'olivier clavel oui pourquoi est il si
important young pour plus alors dans
votre vision avoue du 20e siècle il est
pour moi il est très important parce que
au sein de cette nouvelle manière dont
on va dire de se voir soi-même qui est
la psychanalyse il va il va réintégrer
le mystère où l'irrationnel c'est à dire
que c'est évidemment ce que lui avait
reproché freud mais c'est aussi ce qu'on
peut lui reconnaître comme source de
découvertes et en fait c'est à la suite
de crises successives est en crise qui
suivent à la fois la rupture avec sa
maîtresse la rupture avec young avec
freud et c'est ce qui va arriver à
écrire consignés tous les jours dans son
livre rouge cette espèce de voyage de
l'âme qu'il fait lui où il va rencontrer
tous ces archétypes c'est à dire que ce
qui ensuite il va promouvoir on va dire
comme une la psychologie des profondeurs
qu'elle a vécu sur lui-même d'abord et
il va rencontrer en particules figure
qu'il appelle philémon et qui est une
sorte de sage gnostique et ça ça précède
le moment où on fait tout va y avoir des
fantômes qui vont arriver comme des fous
dans sa maison
dans tous les sens qui vont faire sauter
les portes les fenêtres etc toute la
maison a peur et et freud se met à sa
table 10 jours qu'est ce que qu'est ce
que vous voulez qu est ce que vous les
gars il va devoir prendre une identité
de san juan au stick basilic et il se
rend compte parce qu'en fait les morts
sont encore malades les morts les morts
sont les morts ne savent pas où ils sont
ne savent pas où ils vont ils ont besoin
d aide il croyait encore on va dire aux
monothéismes au christianisme ils
étaient les morts étaient chrétiens ces
acquis dix ans de façon presque ironique
il va falloir leur montrer en fait que
le dieu qui croyaient en dieu n'est pas
dieu que le diable non plus qu'il ya une
multitude multitude de figures qui vont
devoir traverser dont ils vont devoir
comprendre qu'elles sont des doubles de
même des miroirs de même des images
d'eux mêmes et des fictions aussi de
même et que ça veut pas dire qu'il ya
pas une véritable divinité ça veut pas
dire qu'il ya pas un véritable au delà
mais elle est pas dans leur construction
il fallait traverser ces constructions
lyon va avoir une âme une influence
déterminante sur fellini ça c'est
quelque chose je me suis rendu compte en
lisant les témoignages de fellini et en
particulier le tournant du cinéma qu'est
huit et demi d avec les fleurs sauvages
de bergman qui permet de lui aussi très
influencé par ilunga façon personne n'a
le disant très bien mais avec des vrais
sauvages de fleurs sauvages de bergman
personnes berman qui a vraiment un film
de tourner à part dans le cinéma on va
rentrer dans un cinéma qui ne ce noeud
qui n'a plus comme on va dire comme fil
directeur on va dire une une intrigue
narrative avec des bulles lieu fin mai
qui peut partir par tous qui va explorer
en fait l'homme comme totalité et pas
seulement fellini j'ai appris à glisser
dans huit et demi lien c'est à partir de
huit et demi et ça et ça et ça roule le
long de ses films c'est aussi aussi le
moment où fellini devient un cinéaste
qui va voir les morts aussi aisément
arrive dans les films de fellini et les
films fils disait topor sont bondées de
fantômes comme un métro parisien 6
heures du matin ce sera le cas aussi de
cinéastes actuels bertrand mandico qui
pour moi ils sont mais son plus grand
continuateurs à 6 ans et aujourd'hui il
ya aussi il ya aussi la musique oui qui
rentre avec otis redding way par exemple
en tant qu outil de trading qui a signé
parmi les plus belles chansons soul de
son époque ça dure très peu de temps un
quatre ans de carrière il meurt très
jeune dans un accident d'avion mais
pourquoi lui pourquoi il arrive là
pourquoi otis redding parce que otis
redding en fait à anticiper et à on fait
quasiment à pérenniser instantanément
naturellement quelque chose que les
autres hommes vont chercher il ay là il
avait d'emblée c'est la vulnérabilité
c'est l'homme qui pleure c'est l'homme
qui n'a pas peur de se montrer dans sa
fragilité dans sa douceur dans ses
doutes dansez dansez presque danser dans
ses craintes même par rapport à l'être
aimé
c'est un homme c'est un homme doux et
c'est aussi un homme triste mais c'est
un homme capable de la joie montrer sa
tristesse qui a pas de honte il n'y a
pas de honte par rapport à qui il est
acquis il est dans sa vulnérabilité dans
sa douceur c'est peut-être la chose qui
a marqué à mon avis les hommes dans leur
amour de la soul music les hommes et les
femmes la jeu les humains humain ou un
mais la seule musique parce que la seule
musique leur parler de leur
vulnérabilité
mais otis redding l'a fait peut-être
s'est très vite et plus encore que tous
les autres et donc quand il fait sit in
à dawson city dock of the bay ce morceau
qu'il enregistre juste avant de mourir
il meurt entre l'enregistrement et la
sortie du disque là aussi il amène une
espèce de d'acceptation l'acceptation
que le monde va pas ressembler à ce
qu'on en attend c'est quelque chose de
très surprenant à son époque c'est à
dire qu'ils voient le monde et dit le
monde va peut-être pas changé finalement
ça va pas se passer comme je l'attend et
il dit j'ai cette tristesse qui restent
et en même temps c'est pas grave seydoux
je reste là je fais à si je regarde les
bateaux passer c'est quelque chose qu'on
va retrouver chez marvin gaye laisser
quelque chose contre 2 chez john lennon
mais tellement longtemps après et j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup de figures mais c'est
quelque chose qu'ils ont du mal à
trouver et que otis ring à trouver à 22
23 ans avec ce visage on dirait que dans
la déjà 45 c'est
il ya organisé il n'y a pas que des
saints ils ont aussi fait des
dit l etat fils du des murs jeu du type
georges pompidou oui les successeurs moi
j'aime beaucoup georges pompidou désolé
fred ne s'attardera pas sur son stade
face à un mur on va aller parce qu'il
nous reste que trois minutes et que
celui fait 500 pages est qu'il s'agit
pas non plus de remplacer la lecture on
va finir avec philippe qui a dit oui
parce que très important philip k dick
qui rédige l'exégèse elle a besoin de sa
vie
et pour vous l'exégèse ça résume tout le
reste ah oui oui c'est c'est une
expérience inouïe jan filc a dit qu'il a
une il a une expérience mystique qui a
duré deux mois entre février et avril
1974 ou en gros une figure une épiphanie
gnostique une figure qui l'appelle zebra
enfin que lui donne plusieurs noms
s'installe dans son dans sa tête quoi il
parle lui lui explique des choses et
elle disparaît et après une fois qu'elle
a disparu alors il va essayer de
comprendre ce qui lui arrivait de
comprendre en fait qu'est-ce que la
divinité a essayé de lui dire et donc
non seulement il va re lire ses romans
il va re lire énormément énormément de
choses pour essayer de les comprendre
désarticulé et va aussi traversé tous
les systèmes philosophiques politiques
religieux chaque fois on les épouses ans
c'est à dire en le pendant un mois mais
ton il va être 10 fervent pendant deux
mois il va se mettre dans le judaïsme à
fond pendant un an ça va être le
meilleur marxiste qu'on puisse imaginer
mais toujours avec cette idée finalement
que tous ces systèmes
sont comme des à chaque fois des images
que reprend le labyrinthe et que la
vérité se trouve toujours au moment où
le système lui-même commence à se
désagréger et montre autre chose donc
c'est comme une image aussi de c'est une
image de labyrinthe dont il s'agit de
sortir c'est le labyrinthe de l'ensemble
de l'humanité c'est philip k.dick c'est
juste un humain qui re traverse toute
l'histoire de l'humanité et c'est aussi
l'image de parcs d'attraction c'est le
voyage de crapauds vers nulle part cette
vieille attraction de disneyland où on
tourne comme ça et on traverse les
différentes cultures les différentes
machin et et c'est ce voyage là il est
finalement il en vient associé à la fois
on va dire l'émancipation la question de
l'émancipation à la fois social et
intellectuel spirituel le gnosticisme et
d'une certaine façon
on va dire le travail intellectuel le
travail intellectuel la réflexion le
fait de ne jamais lâcher l'exégèse est
on comment dire moi je le crois je crois
croyez l'enquète à l'infini une autre
histoire du 20e siècle et sans sous
titres ça vient de paraître aux puf les
presses universitaires de france ça fait
plus de cinq cents pages merci premier
ciel d'amérique on se retrouve juste
après une pause avec jean charles de
castelbajac
[Musique]
jean charles de castelbajac vous êtes un
fameux dessinateur comme on va le voir
mais d'abord l'image que vous avez
choisie pour illustrer notre époque
c'est la couverture de l pourquoi oui
parce que en arrivant à mon cas ce que
j'ai trouvé cette image qui m'a
interpellé comme comme celle du prix
pulizer il ya des années 80 à 84 par
sean kelly et j'ai ce sentiment j'ai le
sentiment qu'en fait
dans ma longue vie
et que les choses se répètent reviennent
surtout afghanistan d'un surtout en
afghanistan mais aussi
dans tous les pays où où on essaie
d'intervenir où on essaie de changer les
choses d'installer notre culture
occidentale et
cette chose irrémédiable cette femme
qui est obligé de casser ces instruments
de musique de
voilà c'est ce monde
et cette photo formidable
photographe de guerre
donc jean charles de castelbajac
dessinateur un livre sort chez
flammarion intitulé dessin tout terrain
et une exposition vous est consacré du
25 septembre au 9 mai au centre pompidou
dans la galerie des enfants il faut dire
que vous dessinez depuis que vous êtes
tout petit et que vous dessinez sur tout
et sur n'importe quoi c'est peut-être ce
qui caractérise votre style d'ailleurs
on va voir un certain nombre d'image qui
figurent dans ce livre on vous voit se
dessiner sur tout et n'importe quoi oui
d'où ce titre des saintes au terrain
mais je dessine tout est aussi pas
n'importe quoi puisque je dessine mes
émotions je dessine mais manque que je
dessine mais c'est dur j'ai dessiné en
pension ma solitude donc le dessin a
toujours été la com com
un miroir de ma colère de mes angoisses
de ma joie de mai et de cette envie de
cette possibilité de partager parce que
j'étais un petit garçon timide
parce que je suis devenu un adulte avec
plus de certitudes mais le dessin est
toujours un outil un outil est un
instrument absolument extraordinaire
mais pour décider surtout
il faut être armé en permanence vous
avez toujours sur vous je suis armé là
j'ai un certain nombre de choses dans
mes poches 1 g j'ai plusieurs feutre g
décret vous voyez il ya toujours il ya
toujours une espèce de deux séries de
mais je me suis aperçu que je dessinais
très bien sur la neige sur la buée comme
les tous
et qu en soit le sable est en fait ce
détournement de deux supports
c'est la matière et la matière elle
concorde et apporte beaucoup à la
qualité de mon art et de ma création la
couleur aussi je le trouve toujours très
importante dans tous vos dessins
absolument la couleur essentielle alors
ça vient vraiment de de l'enfance parce
que j'avais cette fascination pour le
moyen-âge pour les râles 10 mhz pour la
vaccinologie les drapeaux les blasons et
là les couleurs sont très courtes en
fait la gamme elle est très très
disciplinée pour se reconnaître sur les
champs de bataille il ya de gueule qui
est rouge il ya d'azur qui est bleu ya
sinople kléber il ya sable qui est noir
et argent qui est blanc et iliad à dieu
et il ya or qui est le jaune donc on a
une gamme très concise et comme c'était
ma passion je lisais je dévorais
villehardouin juin bilan pension ou
l'habite du guesclin quand j'ai plongé à
16 ans dans dans le monde qui se
proposait à moi qui étais pop c'était
les années 60 j'ai tout de suite vu les
loups gaudray montlouis les saules
échelle qui étaient directement inspirée
de l'era 10 mhz donc assez marrant
d'ailleurs parce qu'aujourd'hui où dieu
sait s'il ya moins de couleurs dans la
vie
de tous les jours les voitures sont
grises loire les vêtements sont noir
blanc et gris la couleur a quasiment
disparu une série comme game of thrones
monde accorde énormément d'importance
blason dévia mieux on attache de
l'importance aux motifs des blasons il
pas du tout à la couleur
je pense qu'il ya quand même une
évolution
de l'acceptation de la couleur par
exemple je me souviens que dans les
années les années 70 quand je
travaillais avec roger tallon qui est un
grand designer on nous disait qu'il y
avait trois gammes chromatiques 1 il y
avait la gamme des nantis c'était la
gamme de ce qu'ils gagnaient plus de 15
mille dollars par mois blanc blanca ses
tourterelles cédera la gamme des
bourgeois qui était immuable m'a-t-on
dit qui était bleue marine vert
bouteille bordeaux et il rit flanelle et
camel pour les plaids et enfin la gamme
du peuple qui était bam les primaires
surtout les oranje avec du fuchsia et
une petite touche de marron pour la
faire croire qu'on ne décollait pas un
donc notre projet talons c'était de
faire monter cette gamme du peuple en
première ou aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit
quand on voit les vitrines de vuitton ou
du luxe que la gamme du peuple est monté
en première voilà est faux et blanc
thorel voilà on est dans la gamme des
nantis avec une touche quand même de la
gamme du peuple est-ce que vous vos
dessins sont préméditées qu'est ce que
j'y réfléchirai à mr jean celui là par
exemple celui qu'on a là vous aviez si
celui ci est ancien puisqu'il doit être
des halles où il est de 94
je me mettais le soir à dessiner et
j'avais été le dessin cette époque là
était une forme de thérapie
donc il était la résultante de ma
journée alors là je ne sais pas facile
peu importe le moyen tant qu on a
l'adresse donc non est en fait
aujourd'hui
le climax de ma fulgurances c'est depuis
25 ans quand je dessine sur les murs de
paris avec manquerait parce que c'est un
geste complètement médiumnique est
complètement lié à mon inconscient mais
non je ne je ne prémédite pas et même
lorsque j'ai des signes de la mode je
dirais que c'est le dessin qui m'amène
l'idée donc l'accident
inconscient est en place je pense à une
gamme chromatique je pense à une source
historique ou folklorique mais dès que
je dessine c'est le dessin qui amène
l'idée est ce que la mode c'est le
produit dérivé de vos dessins
la mode est l'un des médiums
en lien direct avec avec mes dessins
mais en fait mes dessins m'ont permis
d'être le monstre protéiforme que je
suis
c'est cette personne
inaliénables qui veut toucher tout faire
des couvertures de magazines dessinés
sur les murs
créer des installations comme je suis en
train d'en faire une qui est un peu le
climax de ma carrière cette installation
le peuple de demain parce que
puisqu'elle est là pour la transmission
elle va être où elle va être dans la
galerie des enfants du centre pompidou
présente pendant sept mois et là il
s'agissait il s'agissait de transmettre
donc
je suis passé au travers de deux d'une
sorte de discipline de mon art où j'ai
mis en exergue les principes les plus
importants c'est à dire par exemple les
totems qui est une figure qui revient
régulièrement dans mon travail
les cariatides les drapeaux les signes
et la couleur bien sûr mais certaines
vos dessins sont éphémères
à la craie par exemple dans le sable ou
quand vous dessinez why it sur une vitre
dans l'alu et voulait photographier
systématiquement où la plupart leur
donner les moyens de les photographier
de
en fait je m'aperçois que cette trace
éphémère un
jeu reprend cette phrase de chars qui
dit l'artiste n'a pas de n'a pas besoin
de preuve seuls les traces font rêver
je les pense éphémère mais je les
retrouve bizarrement ses dessins à la
craie par exemple là j'en ai retrouvé à
orly sud qui doit avoir vingt ans vingt
cinq ans il est toujours là oui parce
que je pense que les personnes
s'occupent de l'entretien n'aime pas
trop effacé des anges alors ils sont à
la crème et ils ont une force
charismatique ou peut-être puisque
l'ange existe dans toutes les religions
aussi donc
ils sont pas si éphémère que ça et je me
suis aperçu aussi que la compatibilité
entre la craie le minéral et le minéral
c'est à dire les murs
il peut pleuvoir est soudain l'ange
réapparaît
donc c'est assez extraordinaire il ya
parfois de l'est de l'écriture dans vos
dessins mais c'est encore du dessin
c'est encore du dessin puisque
l'écriture devient un dessin mais ça je
ne suis pas le premier à pratiquer sa
apollinaire beaucoup beaucoup d'artistes
ont fait on fait du contour des lettres
quelque chose qui était de l'ordre du
dessin eux c'étaient des calligraphes
d'eau d'ailleurs disait qu'il ne
destinait pas qui il est et kiki et
c'était une autre forme d'écriture au
fond vous avez tous été une des grandes
jean charles de castelbajac même quand
même très célèbre vous continuiez
bartolone d'ingrandes ça vous êtes
toujours fasciné c'est dit c'est parce
que je préfère ce monde là en fait à ce
monde-là qui était le monde de
l'alternatif que ça soit dans ma pas si
mes passions musicales que les premiers
groupes que j'ai aimé c'est lé yardbird
pas ce qui limitait les oiseaux avec
leurs guitares new york dolls l'edl
parce que c'était totalement une
transgression absolue et d'ailleurs je
suis resté toujours ami avec david
johnson qui dit il avait présenté une
fois je
qui dit qui vit à new york oui mais mes
dessins en fait c'est comme une épée
pour un chevalier ou c'est comme une
canne à pêche pour un pêcheur mon dessin
me permet d'aller au-delà des frontières
daleo d'aller chercher les choses
allaient aller installer ce dialogue et
c'est ce qui me fascine dans ce travail
que je fais avec la galerie des enfants
c'est que ce dialogue avec l'enfance
après une période comme celle qu'on
vient de vivre de kovy doux ou où les
familles ont aussi partagé cette forme
d'inquiétude immobilisme de de suspens
je veux cette exposition comme un
territoire d'expérience on va te lire
dans ce livre on voit des dessins qui
datent du coc vide oui ça vous a changé
votre manière de dessiner ou c'est ça ma
la dent des cinq on voit par exemple il
apparaît une gamme chromatique tout à
fait particulier ils datent de mars je
crois que 19 mars oui 2020 hier deux
jours après le début du confinement
voilà bah c'est l'apparition de tous ses
meilleurs accents beaucoup de basques il
y avait il y avait cette émergence 1 et
surtout il y avait d'émergence de cette
gamme chromatique qui est une gamme qui
vient en fait d'aider des hôpitaux de
campagne du vietnam parce que c'est des
couleurs répulsion
pour pour les pour les moustiques pour
les pauvres pour les insectes et donc je
vois apparaître cette gamme chromatique
est à l'opposé de la mienne en fait
c'est des pastels bajac donc
donc douce et des cinq images est bien
utilisé d'ailleurs le vers des hôpitaux
oui oui c'est c'est ce vers si
particulier qui qui qui servait aux
hôpitaux de campagne en fait ouais les
militaires de toute façon ça vous
appelle ça vous a toujours aussi
beaucoup influencé
oui dans dans plusieurs domaines qu'il a
soit là la splendeur de l'uniforme les
camps
l'installation le camouflage mais ça
c'est une tradition militaire familiale
qui dans mon inconscient doit surgir je
pense est ce que est ce que vous décidez
de tous les jours est ce qui vous est
arrivé parfois de n'avoir aucun dessein
dans la journée mais si je quitte ma
maison sans né peux tu ressens mettrai
mes poches c'est fear factor
je suis totalement manque parce que je
je peux rater une surface que je caresse
dans la rue sur laquelle mon dessin
serait parfait je peux aussi ne pas
rentrer en contact avec un fantôme
descente ou terrasse un gros livre ses
chéquiers l'éditeur d'ailleurs
flammarion gelé 10 et et l'exposition
c'est donc au centre pompidou à partir
du 25 septembre dans la galerie des
enfants merci à la fin de la grève de
demain le peuple que ce sont les enfants
d'aujourd'hui bien sûr merci jean
charles de castelbajac
merci freinet
[Musique]
l'unmis la berline sky arthur en selle
vous formez un célèbre duo de pianistes
classiques à la ville comme à la scène
non seulement vous êtes mariés mais vous
jouez à quatre mains sur deux pianos
tête bêche et vous avez créé le premier
festival en france pour duo de piano le
festival rungis piano piano dont la 2e
et bill édition se tient du 25 septembre
au 4 octobre alors l'image qui symbolise
le mieux notre époque à vos yeux c'est
celle ci
alors c'est encore l'afghanistan comme
j'avoue charles de castelbajac mais
c'est ce musicien qui a été estimée en
arabie c'est juste que ça nous rappelle
de manière très cruelle c'est la petite
histoire dans la grande histoire bien
sûr il ya tellement d'histoires terrible
mais à quel point à quel point la rien
est acquis tout simplement les droits
chèrement chèrement acquis ben non c'est
toujours remis en cause et la culture
particulièrement c'est quelque chose
pour lequel on doit se battre par tous
là c'est évidemment très très symbolique
en afghanistan mais
la culture est attaqué de toute part
toujours partout et on doit se battre
tout simplement
suis absolument d'accord
alors venons au duo de pianistes puisque
c'est le coeur de ce festival le premier
duo de pianistes connu c'était
beaux-arts et sa soeur n'ont
déjà tous les deux je produisais on va
les voir d'ailleurs là avec leur père
ils se produisaient est-ce qu'ils
jouaient de la même manière ce que
c'était les mêmes règles que pour vous
parce que là on les voit tous les deux
joué sur le même piano c'était pas le
même piano à l'époque disons de cadeaux
forte au pianoforte mais oui enfin je
pense que le principe était absolument
le même c'est pas par hasard que l'on
continue à jouer ce magnifique sonates
de mozart pour deux pianos le compte
certes de mozart avec orchestre pour
deux pianos donc oui même bac et les
commencé avant mozart et les cli aussi
le concerto est encore debussy
stravinsky aussi qu'on veut voir
également vous vous êtes très célèbre
alors vous à titre personnel pour avoir
joué chostakovitch
mais mes stravinsky et debussy aussi
jouer absolument en fait dans le xxème
siècle ça c'est vraiment une explosion
de des oeuvres pour deux pianos les
compositeurs commencé à écrire plus en
plus après l'époque romantique en fait
on peut dire que le jouer à deux pianos
enfin deux claviers ça existe depuis que
l'écriture faim depuis que le clavier il
existe un parti au moment où on a écrit
pour un clavier on a commencé à écrire
pour deux et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que depuis toujours qu'est ce qui
motive
l'écriture de ses pièces c'est souvent
le plaisir le bonheur la joie de jouer
avec un proche ce soit un membre de sa
famille vous parliez de mozart et sa
soeur n'a merle mendelsohn et fanny mes
poulains qui est son ami jacques février
20 il ya toujours cette notion de
partage de bonheur de joie
et ça se ressent beaucoup dans ce
répertoire d'ailleurs rapporte à bertoua
qui est beaucoup plus vaste qu on croit
en fonds énormes il ya des milliers et
des milliers et des milliers d'oeuvres
il ya peut-être qu'ils ont pensé combien
concerto pour deux pianos écrite dans je
n'ai aucune idée au départ quand je vous
ai connu je me suis dit bon ils doivent
eux ils doivent ramener un peu pour
trouver des oeuvres mais en fait je me
suis aperçu parce que vous ai dit que
c'était beaucoup plus values sur les 107
106 c'est à dire que tout le monde
connaît j'imagine assez le concerto de
mozart pauvres de piano poulenc
évidemment bac bac et on s'arrête plus
ou moins l'aï pourtant il ya beaucoup
plus de deux oeuvres magnifiques des
banques est intéressant c'est que voilà
c'est il ya des chefs-d'oeuvre pas
seulement un bon c'est pas des
curiosités
c'est très à la mode aujourd'hui de
chercher des choses
parce que tout le monde se spécialiser
puis parce qu'il faut nous faut du neuf
toujours mais là on a vraiment un
répertoire où il ya des chefs-d'oeuvre
qui sont méconnus
papa pas connu tout simplement qui
mérite d'être joué partout dans le monde
et qui si le compositeur était plus
connue ou si c'est elle a été défendue
par pendant dix ans par un certain duo
enfin plusieurs duos en même temps ce
serait dans le répertoire de tout le
monde et les gens se poserait même pas
la question alors on va regarder la
bande annonce de votre festival qui est
composée
d'ex traite de la dernière puisque vous
avez eu le temps de le faire juste après
la première vague de coville avait été
un peu raccourci cette année il sera
beaucoup plus long mais on regarde
justement on va voir et puis après vous
allez expliquer quelles qualités sert au
caire parce que tout le monde peut pas
jouer à 1,80 sur deux pianos
[Musique]
non
m
au
à
on imagine bien le côté performance qui
peut y avoir avoir deux pianistes comme
ça l'un en face de l'autre joué en même
temps se regarde et je vous l'avais fait
remarquer la dernière fois que vous
étiez venu dans cette émission vous
regarder constamment comment jouer face
de l'autre mais on se dit finalement ça
ne peut pas s'improviser ça vous pouvez
pas prendre deux musées deux grands
pianistes et leur dire bâtir vous allez
jouer ensemble on peut leur dire ça on
va voir ce que ça va donner enfin si
vous leur dites cinq minutes avant
d'entrer en scène ça va leur poser un
problème c'est très différent dans le
cas de
deux du jazz là où on a un problème et
dernière baptiste trotignon thomas enhco
qui improvise mais comme le dit si
justement bâtisse l'improvisation sa
s'improvise pas c'est quelque chose de
travailler très en amont vous avez des
décennies d'expérience et en plus ce
sont quand même deux pianistes qui se
connaissent déjà qui ont une sensibilité
identique si vous mettez deux pianistes
de jazz aussi géniaux soit il qui n'ont
jamais joué ensemble pour un concert
comme ça ça va pas marcher il faut une
alchimie faut ce qu'il faut se
comprendre il faut sentir le timing de
la même manière est-ce que ça s'apprend
et ce qui est une école pour apprendre à
jouer
juste et moi
oui non parce qu'il ya beaucoup des
pianistes qui est évidemment plus en
plus aujourd'hui qui est qui a envie de
jouer ensemble il ya des duos du piano
heureusement pour le répertoire etc mais
il n'y a pas une classe de deux pianos
dans le conservatoire en france en tout
cas parce que ça rentre dans le cadre de
musique de chambre musique de chambre ça
peut être aussi tu es au quartz york min
est hissé rien à voir avec cet endroit
on se retrouve très souvent avec ya trop
de pianiste dans le conservatoire qu'il
faut qu'ils fassent leurs diplômes
musique de chambre et on annonce on en
met deux sont sans savoir s'ils vont
s'entendre et en plus le professeur de
musique de chambre qui a obligé me
trouver deux pianistes sessou ça peut
être un prof de violon et flûte qui
gagnerait en répertoire de pierre et
malgré ça que sa compétence les game
bien embêté quand c'est réussi quand
vous avez la pression vous avez fait
tous les deux un concert magnifique
qu'est-ce que vous avez prouvé là que
vous n'approuvez pas d'habitude il ya la
fusion c'est la fusion vous chercher au
oui bien sûr et aussi
c'est la même chose que quand vous jouez
solo sauf que c'est beaucoup plus
difficile parce que il faut que
respirent ensemble il faut qu on
ressentir si moi je sens que arthur par
exemple elle se sent pas bien où ça se
passe quelque chose que je comprends pas
ce qu'est ce qui se passe exactement
évidemment moi aussi j'avais j'ai tout
de suite et al'inverse donc si on est
tous les deux en forme si on a la même
énergie si dans ce cas là ça passe c'est
comme faire l'amour tout simplement l
amérique bien sûr et quand c'est réussi
c'est juste que on a ou alors tout
autour fonctionne de la même manière
pour nos deux on a besoin on se suit
mais on n'a même pas besoin de se
regarder tous avant même la production
du son on arrive à se comprendre ce
suivre ce par l'esm et surtout les deux
pianos qui qui se marient de façon à ce
qu'on sait on sait plus qui joue quoi
comme quand on fait l'amour en voilà de
quoi il faut avoir les deux pianos chez
soi en permanence tous les autres vous
avez deux pianos chez vous oui cette
brèche
3 parce qu'il faut pouvoir travailler
ensemble et séparément donc il peut de
la surface oui ça assez c'est un des
grands problèmes et d'ailleurs si on
revient à l'histoire pourquoi finalement
serait plaint de voir il est moins connu
aujourd'hui c'est aussi pour des raisons
pratiques bêtement et et historique à
l'époque de mozart
la musique se faisait dans les palais
dans la whl l'aristocratie donc il y
avait de la place qu'on pouvait mettre
un clavecin de clavecin 3 clavecin sans
problème au 19e siècle on a d'une part
la musique devient
l'apanage de la bourgeoisie mais dans
des salons privés qui sont beaucoup plus
exigu alors que les pianos e enfle et en
plus c'est le héros soliste romantique
est restée seule bas on ne peut pas lui
adjoindre un deuxième héros alors on
fait comment ces problématiques c'est
seulement avec le la construction des
grandes salles de concert des
conservatoires et c'est que là on
commence à avoir la possibilité pratique
finalement de développer ce répertoire
mais pourquoi réagissent ce festival
c'est comme on dit et les taux les
planètes s'alignent et ouais ça parce
que avant tout nous tous les deux depuis
bientôt cinq ans nous semble urgent y
soit on habite orangis et quand nous
sommes arrivés n'a jamais pensé qu'on va
retrouver dans cette petite ville
tellement riche de
de l'art en fête magnifique théâtre avec
une belle programmation pendant toute
l'année très bon conservatoire aussi
pareil et puis surtout
les élus le maire de rungis qui sont
très ouvertes pour ça et quand on m'a
dit tiens ça n'existe pas un festival
dédié à deux pianos et 80 il pourtant on
sent dans l'air que plus en plus les
musiciens envie de faire ça ils ont dit
ok on va le faire donc c'est comme ça
même pendant pendant la pandémie on a eu
de la chance l'année dernière quand même
on ait réussi à rentrer après donc
goutte
alors très vite au programme cette année
yakhi à part vous deux
l'ouverture c'est jean françois zygel et
andré manoukian que tout le monde
connaît et qui se connaissent bien eux
aussi je suffisamment savoir jouer tous
les deux absolument on a tout vérifié
nationale ile-de-france qui nous
accompagne depuis le début et qui va
continuer avec nous et puis des grands
grands noms du classique philippe
cassard cédric pescia louis lortie
hélène mercier loquace guiniot chasse et
anna guéniot chaîne et avec grand prix
chopin et c'est qu'ils sont tous tes
vrais vrai duo formé et
des superbes jeunes talents ont fait
comme dans les concerts de musiques
actuelles comme les concerts de rock on
met les jeunes talents en première
partie des stars pour être sûr que le
tout le public pourra les découvrir et
après ils ont leur propre concert pour
que pour que tout le monde vienne
vouliez déjà l'année dernière un moment
être sur un camion
dans les rues avec les deux canaux est
ce que cette année c'est possible ils
savent aller sillonner les rues de
rungis grâce à guillaume fabre et son
projet utopia et il a son propre camion
scène déjà prêt avec le piano dedans et
on va aller dans les lieux emblématiques
dans différents quartiers de rungis pour
porter la bonne parole de ces forces
c'est donc du 25 septembre
jusque là jusqu'au 4 octobre merci
d'être venu l'annoncer dans cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]